Lair is with us in Minnesota hi Claire
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Uncle
Dave I've got a doozy for you and I
really need your help okay 319 knocked
me out cold my husband of 22 years
revealed that he had a secret child
who's a few months younger than my
youngest I have four kids my youngest is
7 my oldest is 14 after he told me this
news we tried marriage counseling could
work even the marriage counselor said we
should get a divorce
so he moved out and he moved in with a
new girlfriend
who's also his boss I've been a single
mom to the kids I have a part-time job
I make $19,000 a year he pays the
mortgage of 2735 a month and he gives me
$1,400 every month to feed and clothe
two kids I his voice is also his
girlfriend and his boss determined his
bonus this year so I got a percentage of
his bonus because my lawyer fought for
him I have the bonus of 39,000 I used
part of that to pay off the credit cards
that I've been living on I had borrowed
money from my sister to pay the kid pay
the lawyer keep the heat on and after I
paid off my bills put $1,000 reserve I
have 26 thousand dollars left I know
doesn't have to sell the house the kids
and I because I can't afford a mortgage
for 27 35 a month and I have two
questions
do I just sock away the 26 thousand left
of my ex-husband bonus and use it as a
down payment on whatever new house the
kids and I have to move in or do I kind
of live on it or do I pay my sister and
brother-in-law back because they did
lend loan me money and then the other
crazy thing I have to ask is should I
give up more custody of my kids to work
part-time so I can work more money to
earn more money I'm sorry
I know and you're you're a great guy
Dave I my friend Jennifer in - they
speak to you about five years ago and I
introduced your seven steps to financial
freedom to my husband and he actually
made me choose he said Dave or me and I
chose
him and boy if I had stuck with you I
probably wouldn't be in this mess
well I guess the choice she was thrown
out was apprehend
was a little bit of spotlighting a
little bit of telescoping and what was
to come huh you know he wasn't this guy
when I married him but he is no short
lay there on the edge of that kid yeah
he's always done this he's always been
this guy so anyway the okay so the way
we answer all of these questions is what
takes care of you and the children's
future the best okay and right now
you're in a middle square in the middle
of a hurricane yeah and when you're in
the middle of a hurricane you don't pay
off debt everything's on hold your hoard
cash you - close it's your it's the pad
between you gives you options in the
middle of this mess okay so okay let's
pretend we fast forward a year from now
the divorce is final the house is sold
okay and you've got some money stashed
away still that's been your safety net
because lord knows you need a safety net
right now okay yes now what is Claire
doing for a living then what is your new
career that you're doing to feed your
kids a year from now I don't know I'm an
optician I adjust glasses that you buy
and I'm actually great at my job but
it's only part-time because I've got the
kid fifty five percent of the time and
the ex-husband every other weekend but
the the custody thing is we're not
giving up custody for money that feels
like you're trading your kids for money
but you have to align custody with your
career that allows you to feed you and
your kids and so we have to have
something we're aiming at and right now
you're in the middle of extreme betrayal
a lot of anger a lot of hurt and it's
hard to think clearly about the future
but the answer to your question lies in
the answer to your future and so what do
I do with the kid custody thing do I
trade some of that
for you know whatever so that I can work
more well you may have to that may be
part of your career choice that you have
to do to survive this and come out of
this how old are these babies so the
youngest of seven the oldest is 14 after
his dad left the oldest wanted to commit
suicide so I haven't in therapy once a
week so I can't work quite full times to
keep him alive so there's a lot of a lot
of crisis going on around your place a
lot of things I mean I actually am
pretty lucky I have my face I have my
friends great new job it's good to have
all that when you're in the middle of a
frickin hurricane it's not so good to
say there's a lot of wind blowing around
you right now yeah and so you know the
winds howling outside I hear it I hear
it coming through the plywood right
that's over the windows and so you're in
the middle of storm and that's just
human you know it's a human thing that
you're those betrayal and anger and fear
or real human emotions that happened to
real human beings when you're in the
middle of a storm so I'm not I'm not
denying you the right to have all of
that I want you to have all of that I
don't want it to consume you but I want
to admit that it's there while we're
making this other decision so what I
would tell you to do is calm your spirit
go in the back porch with a cup of
coffee early in the morning for the kids
start and start talking to God about
what he wants you to do with your life
one year from now career-wise and what
are the steps to get there and then how
does that answer what to do with the
money how does that answer what to do
with the custody how does that answer
how quickly we sell the house and how
much we fight for that I'm assuming the
home has no equity barely we bought a
house less than two years ago we're
still paying off PMI we have a
consolidated spousal loan that cannot
separate according to the loan people I
owe 17,000 of that and my soon-to-be ex
Oh
24,000 of that so we've got about 41,000
and college loan debt the car is paid
off it's a hoopty but it's paid off his
girlfriend bought him a new car I've got
the old minivan so I and we day we do
rice and
spaghetti eggs I mean we we are we are
we have a pretty sharp shell bowl but
now I think I think I think you're doing
fine for where you are and then the
question is what does your new optometry
is it you're an optometrist you can make
good money
I don't know not no not up comic not an
eye doctor just not kitchen I just
adjust the glasses oh I see okay well
then I guess I guess I'm you're gonna go
back and whiteboard retail I'm just
gonna step back and say if you're my
little sister
let's get rid of a whiteboard and say
well I didn't didn't know what's gonna
get dealt this hand but it's here now
what do I want to be in this next
chapter what do you got for me God
because he's not surprised by this you
and I are surprised but he's not well
what do you got for me in my next
chapter what do you want me to do
and that'll tell you what to use some of
this money for cuz you may have to go
get tooled up to do some of that and I'm
gonna get out from under that house
payment as quick as I can so that you
can make this money that you have or
Carter for you through the storm here
but just pile up cash and hold on to it
kiddo to UM turn the corner you're doing
the best you can do in a really
difficult situation